ma question s'adresse au ministère de
l'intérieur il ya une dizaine de jours
l'association osez le féminisme a
procédé à deux cents signalement de
milliers de vidéos pornographiques avec
danse et vidéo - la moitié d'entre elles
qui sont en infraction au code pénal
l'industrie pornographique et les sites
comme par exemple jacques et michel
répondent aux pires fantasmes cher
collègue resté 30 calme parce que ce que
je vais vous dire va certainement vous
troublez vous choquer
beurette des sites est prise dans une
cave grosse [__] qui revient du big
l'aide viols collectifs d'ado enceinte
tout cela est accessible sur le net pour
peu que vous rentriez les bons mots clés
les viols sont des vrais violent les
tortures sont de vrais torture toutes
ces vidéos constituent des infractions
pénales apologie de la haine apologie
des crimes de guerre incitation à la
haine raciale viol en réunion
proxénétisme homophobie mais tout
demeure accessible en fait seule la
lutte contre le terrorisme est
réellement traquer sur le net si une
vidéo montrait un violeur en train de se
diviser une femme en criant allah akbar
à mort les kouffar je n'ai pas de doute
dans l'après midi elle serait retirée
mais s'il viole une femme en disant
juste [__] cette vidéo restera
indéfiniment sur le net alors madame la
ministre quelles suites ont été données
aux signalements qui ont été faits à
pharos combien de vidéo retirée et
combien de sites fermés
monsieur le premier ministre ce n'est
pas n'importe quoi je comprends vous de
comprendre vous connaissez pas bien le
dossier monsieur le premier ministre et
je ne vous en voudrez pas il ya un tel
tabou là dessus mais ne dites pas que ce
que je dis n'importe quoi ce que je dis
la triste réalité pour vous répondre
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice d'abord je veux m'inscrire en
faux par rapport à ce que vous
mentionnez sur le retrait et sur le deux
poids deux mesures qui existeraient je
vais vous expliquer pourquoi dire
différemment sur le constat que vous
partagez c'est évidemment très choquant
et le gouvernement condamne évidemment
c'est pratique c'est un sujet grave et
vous savez que nous avons par exemple
présenter de manière coordonnée avec
différents ministres le 15 novembre un
premier grand plan national de lutte
contre la prostitution des mineurs pour
mieux protéger ces jeunes filles et ces
jeunes hommes qui sont exploités par des
filières dans ce cadre là nous avons par
ailleurs en ce sens si parfois il ya
aussi de la prostitution sur ces sites
nous avons aussi renforcé améliorer la
coordination des unités judiciaire et la
police nationale et de la gendarmerie
nationale qui contribuent au quotidien à
lutter nous avons créé un réseau
d'enquêteurs spécialisés qui s'appelle
cyber jambes et je veux rendre hommage à
ces gendarmes parce qu'ils font un
travail extrêmement difficile toute la
journée ils prennent en pleine figure
ces images ces vidéos en 2021 il ya eu
300 enquêteurs formés à l'anc est
notamment sous pseudonyme ils vont faire
des actions de trac pour à les confondre
ce l'a310 enquêteurs spécialisés et 6100
correspondant par ailleurs nous avons
mis en place et diffuser la cellule
nationale de lutte contre les images de
pédopornographie qui administre la base
calliopée qui comparé analysé logiciels
des images d'origine pédopornographiques
pour mieux lutter notamment d'entre avec
interpol puisque ça se passe parfois de
manière internationale je veux dire que
nous avons reçues en 2021 vingt mille
signalements relatifs à des contenus
pédopornographiques adressé à pharos et
comme nous sommes allés voir pharos avec
le premier trait le garde des sceaux ils
nous ont très clairement présenté
l'activité à la fois de lutte contre le
terrorisme mais aussi bien sûr de lutte
contre la pédopornographie c'est aussi
pour cela qu maintenant farrow s'est
ouvert 24 heures sur 24 pour prendre les
signalements également la nuit enfin je
veux rendre hommage aux agents de
l'office central de répression des
violences aux personnes l'ocr vp qui
travaille au ministère de l'intérieur
jour et nuit avec des agents qui nous
ont expliqué à quel point les enquêtes
qu'il menait était parfois trop même ses
angles pour eux mêmes c'est eux qui sont
à l'origine des récents coups de filet
qui ont permis notamment pendant le
confinement d'arrêter des centaines de
pédo criminels grâce à l'action délicate
qui l'ont mené en ligne et je veux les
salue et je vous remercie
madame la présidente
mais bien sûr madame la ministre que
c'est traumatisant de traquer ces vidéos
et c'est tellement traumatisant que ce
sont des citoyennes et des citoyens
qu'ils le font et quand dans palais nuit
comment vous expliquer malgré tout ce
que vous venez de nous dire qu'il faut
que ce soient des citoyens qui portent
plaintes des citoyens qui saisissent la
justice les citoyens qu'ils fassent et
signalements pharos pourquoi tout ce que
vous nous décrivez
n'est pas suivie d'une d'une cessation
de ces sites d'une fermeture de ses
sites et d'un retrait de six vidéos
parce que malgré tout tout ce que vous
nous dire tout ce que j'ai racontée
c'est toujours sur le net